hello friend I'm rich stocks from the
healthy Christian broadcast in 1997 I
heard a cassette tape by Dr Joel wallet
called Dead Doctors Don't Lie Dr wck
teaches that we all have the potential
to live healthy lives well beyond the
age of 100 and if you give your body
what it needs it will do amazing things
I want to invite you to join millions of
people who've already heard Dr walck's
life-changing message now you can hear
this message free of charge on our
website at Mineral doctor.com
here are three simple steps you can take
right now to put you on the path to a
longer healthier life listen to Dr
wallick's message schedule your free
health evaluation schedule a free phone
consultation we have an experienced team
of people standing by ready to help you
with your health and well-being free
wellness teaching free health evaluation
free phone consultation all found at
Mineral doctor.com we look forward to
hearing from you and helping you reach
your full healthy potential